I know a lot of people complain about  cultural appropriation I don't care all  right I don't care if you do yoga I  don't care if you drink tumeric and act  like you made it up none of that bothers  me do it all I don't care  all I'm asking is can you guys please  for the love of God learn how to say in  the Mustang I can't under you don't have  any idea how much it hurts in Indians  ears to hear namaste it I will drive a  [ __ ] screwdriver in my ear if I have  to keep hearing namaste you sound like a  [ __ ] idiot also it just means hello  the [ __ ] he is saying this at the end of  yoga for what higher level of vibration  do you think you're reaching  but clasping your hands together and  mispronouncing hello  like listen to them they need this and  to help you understand how [ __ ] crazy  it drives you imagine you went to India  and all the Indian people try to bond  with you and by greeting you they were  just like a high low  [Applause]